Let's talk about theme 1 in agg SP for the class of 1st.
It is of course democracy today.
The first thing we're going to talk about,
it is naturally the introduction.
So,
democracy,
democracies,
what are the characteristics today?
The introduction will allow you to understand
what is 1 democracy
and are there many,
that is,
are there different kinds of democracy
in the world ?
We will also compare democracy
and even authoritarian regimes
to understand the distinctions a little bit.
So certainly,
there are many kinds of democracy,
nevertheless all will be based on the same
universal declaration of
human rights of
mille-neuf-cent-quarante-huit.
I want to die with you
4 important points to make your condition
1 democracy.
I am not asking you to create your own state,
it's not possible, ok,
let's do it this way.
1st thing,
namely the separation of the 3 powers,
executive,
legislative and judicial.
Anything else?
Well,
everyone will be subject to the same rules,
to the same right and duty.
It is therefore equality before the law,
the fact that there are fundamental freedoms,
that is, normally,
we can't remove them,
they are rooted in society,
the press, the,
the expression et cetera et cetera.
And then,
to form all this beautiful little world,
free and fair elections will be needed.
With this in it,
you add 1 political pluralism.
This means that there are several choices of parties
These elections must be by universal suffrage
and also they must be regular.
So as long as there is 1 democracy
but that a president remains for life
and more elections.
Here are my friends!
Goodbye, see you soon!